Super Bowl of course coming up this week
Anthony Lucas first headline cares about
the Super Bowl
it's from the real Bowl it's called the
Pro Bowl it went down here about I eat
my cereal from with my hands because I
the only Bowl I care about is the Pro
Bowl I just threw a dog food on the
floor cuz I'm all about the probe a lot
of the football world this week I don't
own a toilet just sits on the ground in
the corner there's only one Bowl I care
about and it's the Pro Bowl
it's what the NFL season is geared
towards what's all about everything is
just all about the Pro Bowl and you know
but that wasn't always the case
back when it was in Hawaii after the
Super Bowl wasn't that big a deal now
that it's it's it's in between the end
of the playoffs in the Super Bowl and
it's in Orlando the best of America now
it's now it's number one there is some
concern this week that the Pro Bowl was
so exciting people are really not gonna
be into the Super Bowl anymore it was so
I mean everyone's talking about the one
play you know and we're not going to get
into we're not gonna get into the X's
and O's but it was a beautifully coached
game and the players showed a real
passion I think that's what people are
talking about
even during the Super Bowl is how much
passion I mean those guys let left it
all out there on the field all on the
field do you often talk about oh there's
not as much pass rush in the Pro Bowl
mhm not this provo oh my god this Pro
Bowl it was almost like both to both
that the offense was pass rushing doing
I mean they were so into they were so
into it and just the stats I mean
unbelievable it was like it was like and
I can think about the NBA all-star game
how much fun that is and how much
offense there is and then you take a
look at the NH NHL all-star game imagine
if the basketball players had to put on
ice skates that's what this Pro Bowl was
like and what a tough week really for
Stephen a Smith who's famous for being a
Cowboys hater and in Jason Garrett
especially as a guy the coach of the
Cowboys
that he picks on quite a bit after
watching what Jason Garrett did on
Sunday night in Orlando case closed
Jason Garrett saved his job probably
saved a lot of jobs during that Pro Bowl
and you know I don't have the final
score in front of me but it was amazing
it was I just I loved the Pro Bowl more
than anything I wish they could play it
I wish they could play it twice a year
and the skills competition are you
kidding me
hmm all those skills every one of them
there wasn't a single skill that I was
like that's more of a that's more luck
or a gift it was all skills what throws
what throws what happens is oh my god
yeah I mean I've in plays they've really
put the pro in Pro Bowl this year
John Coughlin was a two-time United
States Paris champion in figure skating
Anthony died by suicide last week in
Kansas City Missouri he had recently
been suspended from the US Figure
Skating he was 33 years old so this had
nothing to do with the Kansas City
losing to the Patriots this was just
what do you know why he happened shortly
thereafter yes but he was and what was
he suspended for officially there's not
a reason but there has been some
reporting that there were sexual assault
allegations that that he was suffering
from yes I love
listen suicide is an important important
topic a very serious topic but when
someone's just like I screwed up so bad
but I'm gonna fit I mean I'm pulling the
plug I think it's great I always think
is you're just like I don't want to go
through a trial you know I mean like I
don't I don't have to explain this to my
mom I'm just gonna go I always think I
always think that's great because at
first it was like oh what happened this
is some horrible tragedy this guy was
like a champion and we worked with you
know trained people I think I'm sure
kids were involved in some way but
you're just like oh I'm you look you
guys want me to you guys I'm gonna get
punished for this you know what I got my
I got plans of my own
and I'm just gonna see while later see
you on the other side I I think I find
that delightful I was wondering where
you could find the lightness in this
story going in but I do find myself
laughing at you're ridiculous like I
believe like when people are like oh
you're this this is a child molester why
didn't they just kill themselves I'm
like yeah I understand that I agree with
that but when you kill yourself
afterwards it's just kind of like I'm
not gonna let you guys win like yeah i
sexually assaulted all these people and
I'm not gonna face any punishment for it
I'm out I didn't even like ice skating
anyway let's move on to a lighter
subject let's talk about a nurse in the
Phoenix area who was arrested this week
after it was found out he raped and
impregnated a woman in a vegetative
state yeah a couple of weeks ago you
probably heard about the story this
woman in a coma and she got killed built
she was in a coma and she all of a
sudden she's pregnant and they're like
oh we're in trouble
the hospital is in trouble we're gonna
get to the bottom of this and you knew
they were gonna solve it right away
because all you do is you look for the
happiest nurse only so many people going
in and out of that room
which one's the happiest he did it I'm
surprised this guy didn't pull a pull a
figure skater and and just be like I'm
not gonna I don't have to answer these
questions I don't have to look someone
in the eye over this but I'm glad they
did get him although like okay it was
that is that one of those facilities
like an assisted care facility you're in
a coma I'm a big fan of like if I'm in a
coma pull the plug I don't want to live
like this even if they're like there's
some rough possibility in 20 years
they'll figure it out like if I'm asleep
for more than 24 hours I'm out I mean
who's in charge right now like do you
have it written down that I do not have
a living will I've just told enough
people that I hope that they would be
like he wouldn't want this
but when I do do a will I will say you
know pull the plug immediately get on
that yeah but if I was in a coma you
know do what you do what you want you
know I mean maybe I'm not gonna say that
it's like it's a good thing but I'm not
I'm not worried about it
it's like it's like you know necrophilia
mmm who's the victim you know well maybe
the families of if you if you see it
yeah sure otherwise you have no idea but
yeah that's it's necrophilia is better
than having sex with someone in a coma I
would like in what way show the picture
because the one person is dead and one
person is a lot but like it's blessed of
a victim thing you know I mean are you
guys so you guys are telling me if you
were to come up like maybe I'll do this
all of a living will but if I'm in a
coma for a little while do what you went
to me that's part of the will over Juvia
or would you guys be like don't touch me
I mean I don't like would you let
someone have sex with you if you were in
a coma no I mean I'd hope not
like yeah the that woman's impregnated
now yeah that's true I mean that's a
bummer
like if you're gonna if you're gonna
have sex with someone in a coma like
youth protection that's a bummer finally
I didn't think about the kid who comes
out of I just assumed the term the
pregnancy wouldn't go that far
now he just said she just had the baby
she just had the baby
is she still in a coma yeah what I just
like that when they found the baby the
baby's doing well when they saw the bump
they were just like oh geez oh we're
getting we're getting to talking to
there's gonna be a meeting at corporate
over this you can't do it nurses this is
why male nurses get a bad rap whenever
whenever nurse kills a bunch of patients
it's always a female nurse but whenever
a nurse knocks up someone in a coma
it's always
dude why is that
[Music]
you